greetings Nephilim and welcome to the
patch to 400 overview my name is brandy
camel also known as Neville Estes
community manager for Diablo 3 I'm here
to guide you through our latest content
pack patch for Reaper of souls we've got
plenty to cover so let's get started
the first major addition in catch to
forró is the release of an entirely new
zone gray hollow islands this mysterious
island is only available in Adventure
mode and can be accessed by traveling to
act 5 and clicking on the gray Hollow
Island Waypoint at the top right of a
man this stormy forested Island is home
to terrifying new enemies a bundle of
new bounties and is steeped in mystery
this isn't the only new corner of
sanctuary to explore
to find the first new zone we've
expanded head to the ruins of Szechuan
waypoint in act 3 and turn around there
you'll be able to explore the eternal
woods the snowy hunting grounds of the
fierce Yeti
we're also delving into the history of
the skeleton king himself the Royal
quarters are now open for exploration
and can be found by heading to lay Oryx
Manor in act 1 these areas are packed
with unique monster populations and
offer new sets of bounties to spice up
your adventure mode experience there are
even a few new secrets to uncover the
class sets can grant incredible amounts
of power and we want to give players the
opportunity to master these sets inside
and out
enter set dungeons a feature designed to
test your mettle with a punishing series
of trials and once you've obtained and
equipped a full six piece set you can
acquire a clue to where you should
travel next find the hidden location in
adventure mode and a portal to your set
dungeon will appear these dungeons have
static layouts and monsters and are
infinitely repeatable deaths in a set
dungeon is not permanent even for
hardcore players still these challenges
are not for the faint of heart shouldn't
be taken lightly
those who can master these trials will
receive exclusive cosmetic rewards
including new clasp and residuals
penance and even special wings
there are both basic completion and
mastery level rewards so the truly
dedicated will stand above the rest
we've made a number of revisions to
seasons in patch 2 for up first we're
introducing the season rebirth feature
which allows you to take an existing non
seasonal hero and instantly transform
them into a fresh level one season
character while your character name and
hours plate will persist all other
accomplishments are left behind in your
non seasonal records this includes
achievements completed and crafting
recipes learned in addition any gear you
had equipped will automatically be
mailed and can be collected by non
seasonal characters for up to 30 days if
you want to jump straight into a season
the moment it launches this is the
fastest way to get back in the action
there are also a few other major changes
heading to seasons first we've decided
on a set lengths for seasons starting
with season 5 which will last
approximately three months second we've
removed season exclusive Legendary's and
replace them with a new reward called a
drug skip by completing the first four
chapters of the season journey you will
receive all six pieces of one of your
class sets which set you earn for a
given class will change with each season
finally new cosmetics will be rewarded
for completing the season journey each
season will reward a portrait frame
while completing chapter four will
reward either a pennant a pet or set of
exclusive wings these rewards will
change with each season so there's
always a reason to come back and join
the fun
in this patch we've focused on
revisiting class sets ranging from
complete overhauls to balance tweaks and
adjustments we've shown off some of
these revisions already so be sure to
watch our preview video and read our
patch notes for more information but
that's not all over 50 new legendary
powers have been added to the game this
includes entirely new items and new
powers added to Legendary's giving you
plenty of shiny new loot to hunt for
with all these new items you're going to
need a place to put it all once patch to
400 launches all players with the Reaper
of souls expansion will immediately be
able to purchase one additional stash -
starting in season five players who
complete the Conqueror stage of the
season journey will unlock another stash
tab up to a maximum of ten total tags
console players who install the to 400
patch will find the maximum amount of
stash space has also increased from 240
slots to 350 patched to 4 oh is now live
and crammed full of even more features
and changes that we just couldn't cover
here for more information about the
latest patch head over to Diablo 3 comm
or click the link below to view the
patch notes that's everything we have
for you today
so thanks for watching and we'll see you
in sanctuary
you